in the summer of 2010 this video of an
armed raid on a health food store went
viral on august 3rd 2011 for the second
time in a little more than a year Rossum
foods a health food co-op in Venice
catering to raw food enthusiasts was the
target of a multi-agency government raid
they took everything first of all they
took all our raw milk which is probably
800 gallons of raw milk and threw it
down the drain it probably in the range
from 30 to 40 thousand dollars where the
produce unlike the 2010 raid however
this time the club's manager James
Stewart was arrested he's strong he's
but he sounded really weak and he
sounded really a bit disheartened but
how you know he sound like a man who got
hit from behind and and got the wind
knocked out of him the Los Angeles DA's
office would not comment but offered a
press release and documents showing that
Stewart along with farmer Sharon Palmer
and her associate Eugenie block have
been charged with four felonies and
several misdemeanors some of the charges
include processing milk without
pasteurization operating an unlicensed
milk plant conspiracy to improperly
label food products and keeping eggs at
an improper temperature Stewart is being
held on 123 thousand dollars bail Palmer
for a hundred twenty one thousand and
block for 60,000 while reason TV was on
the scene at Rossum employees received
jailhouse call from Stewart who's
calling for a rally outside the LA
courthouse before his bail hearing on
the morning of August fourth
house how does that make you feel cure
him oh gosh reasontv spoke with stuart
after last year's raid and he explained
that he was being targeted because his
private membership club purposely flouts
FDA and USDA guidelines in order to
provide truly raw foods to its members
it's how nature provides the food
without the man becoming involved in
pasteurization homogenize a shin
processing of any kind the press release
from the DA's office alleges that
Stewart illegally sold raw goat milk to
an undercover agent it is legal to sell
raw dairy in California but the DA says
Rossum lacked the proper licenses and
permits to do so the customers and
volunteers at Rossum are unhappy with
what they see is the persecution of an
alternative lifestyle in which another
right to
eat whatever they it's good for you the
right to choose a lot of people don't
want people to have the right to choose
and I believe this is just a witch hunt
against James we have created Rossum to
be a private Association know the
difference between public and private
because we've given our power over far
too long claiming ourselves to be public
and saying government I'm idiot I'm an
idiot at making choices for myself you
have the power to make the choice for me
for more reason TVs coverage of the
government's fight against raw food
click now